the Senate Intelligence Committee is
holding a hearing this morning about the
ongoing threat to US elections the
committee released its first report on
Russian interference in the 2016
election yesterday
it suggests that states need more
resources the report urges the
government to quote clearly communicate
that an attack on our election
infrastructure is a hostile act Oklahoma
Republican James Lankford is a member of
the Senate Intelligence Committee he
joins us from Capitol Hill for an
interview you'll only see this morning
on CBS this morning
senator Lankford good morning it's good
to have you with us thank you good to be
with you let me start with this
communicating to any country that would
meddle in the u.s. elections that it is
a hostile act
CIA director outgoing CIA director says
Russia is in continuing to interfere and
he expects them to interfere in the next
election given that and given this
hostile act notion what's your view of
the president's congratulatory phone
call to Putin yesterday well let me let
me take on a couple of things there one
is I would assume Russia would continue
to be able to press in as I would also
expect sessions like North Korea or Ryan
or Iran or domestic activist groups that
just want to be able to stir a problem
to be able to follow the example that
Russia laid down so they did it this
time they showed it could be done now
I'd expect there be other copycats and
other folks to engage so I would expect
that we would be more diligent next time
to be able to help communicate that to
our States the last time we communicated
that to the States it came out as a
bulletin from the FBI saying hey watch
out for these IP addresses they may be a
problem but it didn't really state what
was happening nor the seriousness of it
so that's a big issue as far as
president Trump calling President Putin
and to congratulate him obviously
President Obama did the same thing when
President Putin won last time the Russia
has not been our friend for a very long
time that's consistent but I would hope
to the president every time that he
talks to Putin would bring up things
like arms race issues he would bring up
human rights issues and he would bring
up election security President Obama did
congratulate but he also reportedly told
President Putin to knock it off when it
came to interfering with the elections I
just wonder if you can you can tell the
states to be more vigilant but why not
take it to the head end which is if it
US intelligence officials believe the
Russians are
behind this a message communicated
directly from the President to the
President of Russia would seem to be a
very effective way to say knock it off
until they agree the Treasury Department
has now put sanctions down on Russian
companies and on Russian individuals
when Muller did the indictments about a
month ago of these Russian individuals
that that clearly we're trying to do
through social media meddling in our
elections the White House responded by
putting sanctions on those individuals
in starting that process Department of
Homeland Security a year ago started the
process of trying to be able to engage
on election security will hear that
today in the testimony and will ask the
question in public well we have asked in
private for a year what are we doing to
actually help protect our elections in
the future and we'll hear their progress
of what they've done
providing greater access providing
security clearances to individuals
getting clear lines of communication
both directions between States and
Department of Homeland Security to be
able to cut this off in the future
senator if the president reportedly did
ignore his advisers explicit warnings
not to congratulate Vladimir Putin
during their phone call are you
concerned that he will not heed their
warnings and their advice when he speaks
with kim jungeun I really don't know
what the adviser said obviously the the
meeting with Kim jong-un is
exceptionally important it should be
well scripted and should be well done by
all of our State Department and by the
White House as well to be able to engage
there are a lot of issues not only
Americans that are currently held
captive in North Korea the nuclear
issues with North Korea that are clear
that are threatening the entire region
but it's an extremely important meeting
in a meeting that's historic in many
ways that hasn't happened in decades and
decades so it needs to be right and it
needs to be clear because we face a very
real threat we haven't seen much
pushback on this Washington Post story
that the president did not listen to his
advisors when they said do not
congratulate Vladimir Putin does that
concern you it doesn't quite frankly any
president can do what the president
chooses to do you can go back as far as
President Reagan was advised multiple
times not to save mr. Gorbachev tear
down this wall he was advised by the
State Department and multiple advisors
don't say that word that's one of the
most famous lines from President Reagan
so again presidents say what presidents
choose to say but they also need to
understand they carried the weight of
the entire United States so I would hope
president is careful in what they say
including this one well before we
weren't out of time Stephen Colbert had
a little fun at your expense you and
your colleagues yesterday I'm sure
you've seen that video but we want to
play it and hear your reaction to it
senator hope you're a good boy I call
with President Putin and congratulated
him on the victory his electoral victory
today a bipartisan group of senators
gave a press conference about our
response to Russian cyber attacks and
they were asked about that call
[Applause]
[Music]
it's no bomb
[Music]
my god
senator Lankford hope you've got your
sense of humor this morning bug dude did
that did the question throw you or did
you guys just decide we're not going to
answer it and what did you think about
that Colbert bit none of us had heard
that the president had called and had
congratulated Putin so obviously we had
all been in Intelligence hearings that
morning we'd not even heard that that's
the first time any of us had heard it
and Stephen Colbert is correct if I'd
have had a smoke bomb I would have used
it just to be able to slip out because
we were all caught off guard thing and I
don't even know what to be able to say
and that was as you can tell from the
videos of bipartisan group all staring
at it thinking I have no response
it was unison no response there and
senator quickly before we let you go I
just want to get your thoughts on the
data mining scandal it's a Senate
Intelligence Committee gonna want to be
hearing from Facebook executives or
Steve Bannon and Jared cushion for that
matter who said that they've worked for
and used Cambridge analytic oh yes we
have in the past and we will continue to
that Cambridge analytic has been on our
radar for a very long time but this is
also brings up a big issue that you all
have followed in the past and many other
folks have as well that's the issue of
the data mining from Facebook for a very
long time this has been a decade in the
process multiple campaigns going back to
the Obama campaign the Senate campaigns
other campaigns and quite frankly every
marketer across the country have been
able to get access to all of this
personal data for individuals and when
people push accept that I'm gonna accept
all of the privacy standards they assume
there are things that are private
they're finding out now all that data
has been sold and has been sold for
years so there are multiple issues here
both on Americans privacy for their
information on campaigns how they
function and particularly the
presidential campaign as well senator
Lankford thank you so much for joining
us and for being a good sport about
laughing at yourself thank you I can
tell you thank you can you could take it